barbara supernett nicht willkommen heute
seinen neuen video euch mal wieder
finder gesagt hey wendet wie
irgendwelche videos ein wo irgendwas
macht die zahlreich getan allerdings
muss ich vorher eine ganz kurze
geschichte erzählt luca die letzten zwei
wochen mit seinen eltern unterwegs
letzten drei tagen nur mit seinen
helfern der ganzen familie in hamburg
weil die familie hat was die feier der
fahrer hatte geburtstag die eltern
landes kanu geholfen sein auto gestiegen
und dachte hey hamburg ist von bielefeld
habe man normal durchkommt beispiel
nennt er rette mich insofern künftig los
um 12 oder mit sich um ein video machen
kann wenn ich jetzt gerade auf dem tacho
ist heil geblieben
ich habe sechseinhalb stunden für diesen
zweck gebraucht gelegen so lange dauert
ja auch mehr hartz iv stellen wir haben
einmal einer vollsperrung eigentlich
wollte mich heute um 18 uhr komplettiert
vom auto da hat die gegenwart und dann
haben wir uns gedacht hey jetzt sind wir
schon hier nach vollsperrung gefahren
einfach mal ab und sonne bier einen
besseren kleinen bauern land weg finden
und dann standen wir auf einmal mitten
in einer kuhherde in einer kuhherde
landwege zurückgefahren hat irgendwann
wieder geboren und jetzt bin hier und
jetzt fangen mit den videos besser
bescheid freunde ich hatte heute täglich
einen vernünftigen start in den tag
schön frühstück da die geschäftsausweise
dort junge freunde
was soll ich denn dazu noch bergauf
beschweren kann ich mich da
normalerweise eher weniger jetzt gucke
ich mir je das nächste video an und da
hat jemand sein papier und in papier
steht lucadou stinkt ja also ich hab ein
echter nicht geduscht
[Musik]
also wir sind uns alle darüber einig
dass die lukas kling ist doch einen
zettel geschrieben hat das kann man
immer machen halt video allerdings hat
sie sich noch einem heliumballon gekauft
und die ihn jetzt in den himmel steigen
lassen mit der botschaft luca du stinkst
wenn irgendwer und verglich die balance
finden sollte wurde landete dingo
abgestürzt ist geplatzt
gerade mode macht ein foto von euch mit
diesem zettel und den ballon ladedruck
meter und die krise benutzte das was wir
auf diesem video bisher kennen konnten
war ein mädchen was auf einem karussell
das bis hin zum spielplatz geriet ich
frag mich an der stelle auch in talent
folgt also auch wie irgendwie salze
darunter macht oder aber egal
wir haben jetzt mädel die im schwimmbad
ist wie wird wohl von ihrer freundin
oder ihrem freund dort gefilmt und wie
geht jetzt quasi auf den beckenrand zu
und jetzt setzt sie an meine damen und
herren wie versucht vielleicht ein rad
zu machen oder sie gibt einfach nur ihr
beiden weise pinkeln muss dabei auf
jeden fall passiert irgendwas ich bin
gespannt ob wir wirklich wählen kann
oder ob es wieder eine dieser dummen
luca reagiert die das ist wo sie einfach
auf die fresse zieht dabei meine damen
und herren filme abgeschaut
[Musik]
schaut euch diese fehle hier bitte mal
an
also ich hab euch jetzt hier eingefügt
und die leute die ganze zeit auf replay
ich weiß nicht ob das so gewollt war
aber es geht leicht danach aus dass
ihren kopf nur minimal von einer bösen
platzwunde da weg gekriegt hat ich mit
dem 400 noch mal es ist cool die fläche
hier ist beschädigt aber das ist mir
scheißegal okay kann man immer so stehen
lassen
die fläche da hinten ist beschädigt aber
es ist egal
die fläche hier ist beschädigt aber das
ist nicht sicher ob elia ist jetzt
beschädigt
deutschland braucht man ganz zu
patriotischen blieb deutschland ein land
der grenzenlosen möglichkeit wunderbare
landschaften wunderbare strafen ein
steuergerät und rechte sehen das
weltweit seinesgleichen sucht ich bin
stolzer bürger an diesem lande wenn ich
allerdings aus dem fenster schaue wenig
regen regen und nochmals regen im sommer
warum deutschland wir können doch
darüber reden
versuche ich gerade mit einem land zu
reden
[Musik]
ich finde mein herz ist gerade davon
geflossen flogen nicht geflossen lücke
ich war jetzt leider zwei bis drei
wochen unterwegs wegen tumoren dann
einen tag zu hause dann urlaub dann drei
tage hamburg und so aber jetzt bin ich
halt wieder kurz bei meinen eltern und
dann ab morgen bin ich halt wieder ein
zwei monaten nur in köln und ich freue
mich am allermeisten darauf digital
piano und einfach nur ganz kurz ich weiß
dass wir sehr viele video außerdem
heftiger reagiert eingesendet werden wo
leute ihr talent zeigen allerdings
müssten verstehen dass diese wäre hier
natürlich auch ein bisschen daraus
besteht eine dumme videos kommt sobald
ich meine es macht ja keinen sinn wenn
ich die ganze zeit irgendwelche talente
einnehme und die ganze zeit immer nur
das ist gut da kommt das ist gut dass
ich nicht jedes video was unter dem
hashtag luca reagiert eingewendet jedoch
ein video nehmen kann und so weiter und
so fort und den machen weiter mit dem
nächsten jahr
warten warten warten auf alle ebenen von
die senioren zocken und ist jetzt
wirklich okay die person die mir dieses
video eingeblendet hat auf jeden fall
sehr häufig ende war der fall
mittlerweile alle verstanden ich weiß
nicht was die apple entfernt
das rtl weit ich das beurteilen kann
aber viel wichtigere frage hättet ihr
bock darauf dass ich auf der gamescom
also am dienstag oder mittwoch bin ich
bei den youtube standort und wetter dort
live streams machen hättet ihr doch
darauf dass ich mit den senioren einen
livestream mache aus meinem youtube
kanal wo wir ein game zur probe fragen
beantworten wenn ihr doch hat dann lacht
man leichter und weiter heißt es dass
ihr da bock drauf haben dann hat mir da
noch oder nicht gerade liegt das hat mir
ein paar mal geschenkt als eine art
liefert und optimal bagatellschäden luca
in dem t shirt schlafzimmer
[Musik]
in meinem buch und den baum aus etf
kollegen das klo ich weiß nicht wer von
beiden zuschauer im kika abendsendung
baumhaus guckt oder so aber danke für
das video das was ihr vom video meine
damen und herren wenn wir euch gefallen
hat das geld macht und wenn ihr freute
sich mit den seniorinnen einen
livestream mache ich wollte noch mal
ganz kurz zu meinem krankheit video
sagen was ich vor zwei wochen war schon
hochgeladen habe allerdings ab ich seit
drei wochen auf meinem kanal noch vor
produzierte videos gebracht das heißt
das hier ist das erste video was sich
hochladen seit zwei drei wochen alle
videos die hier also in den letzten zwei
wochen gesehen habe waren also
eigentlich vor produziert das heißt alle
von tumoren aufgenommen und dann waren
sie kommen zumal entweder zu hause und
hatte wieder diese krasse panik
anhänglichkeit doch einfach deine fresse
ich war nach dem rennen auf jeden fall
wieder zu hause hatte dann halt diese
kasse panikattacke hat darüber das video
gedreht und dann zwei tage später kann
man halten sogar produzierten videos
online und da haben mich einige
zuschauer oder einige leute die diese
videos zeitgewinn ameise zuschauer ich
bin dumm tut mir leid kommentare
geschrieben von wegen er warum bist du
denn jetzt wo kraft unterwegs und
brachte hier wissen wir mehr antonius
verschiedener frankreich video das
krankheit video war also eigentlich das
aktuellste video gerade auf meinem kanal
nach dem was ihre qualität des mbc
kompliziert gerade ich wollte nur danke
sagen für diese enorm positive resonanz
unter meinem krankheit video also ich
habe so viele nachrichten von euch
bekommen so viele kommentare so viele
male bekommen von eltern von zuschauern
die irgendwie physiotherapeuten
physiotherapeut psychotherapeuten sind
vollidioten mit hilfe gegeben haben ihre
hilfe angeboten hätte alles tool ist
wirklich in den letzten zwei wochen mir
eigentlich komplette angetan ich hatte
ja auch gar nichts für youtube gemacht
alle sachen wie gesagt vor produziert
natürlich ein bisschen was auch immer
ganz nett gemacht und so weiter und so
fort aber ich habe mir wirklich sehr
viel ruhe angetan auch die zeit jetzt in
hamburg mit meiner familie mit mega gut
getan ihr fehlt natürlich noch ein
bisschen stressig weil ich jetzt noch
mal die mündliche bachelorarbeit prüfung
habe dann kommt die
zum video der woche wo wieder sehr viel
zu tun aber danach wirklich komplett
frei und wollte auch wirklich einfach
mal dann irgendwann eine woche irgendwo
an den arsch der welt fahrer alleine und
mir einfach mal ein bisschen ruhe antun
wollte mich auf jeden fall nur dafür
bedanken dass er mir so viel kraft
gegeben hat sage ich mal
und so viel raum ein gartenreich
hörnchen einfach wirklich keine sachen
ihre menschlichen arm bricht dann hilft
es natürlich nicht wenn ich mich mit
einem kollegen unterhalten der harmos
trotzdem eine schöne sache und wieder
ist vorbei und jetzt kommt das auto
dankeschön allawi cruz erwartet ihr
solltet ihr von ihr könnt jetzt immer
innkanal abonnieren oder hier in meinem
kopf stecken jetzt sind jetzt für andere
videos und bands leicht wenn wir auch
die glocke klicken dann bekommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]